hi i'm dr niv o'hara i
am the ceo and one of the co-founders of
biosha
my background is i have a phd in
evolutionary biology with a focus in
genomics
um and we launched viosha out of cornell
tech and we focus
on precision infectious disease
discovery leveraging next generation dna
sequencing tools
to profile and diagnose disease
we are in a medical crisis in infectious
disease due to outdated and limited
testing tools
um this is what's been going on before
the pandemic but the pandemic
has definitely underscored different
issues so
uh generally hospitals and clinicians
use outdated technology from the 1800s
uh so this is usually culturing based is
the primary tool
where we you know you grow a sample in a
in a dish and you look through a micro
microscope to describe it
and diagnose um and this is used for
bacteria
and fungi there's a lot of limitations
here because you are
limited by the rate of growth of the
pathogen um
and then a lot of species can't be
cultured um it's estimated that
somewhere
under five percent of species can
actually be cultured
um so while there's utility there
there's also a lot of limitations
um and similarly for viruses
there's limitations in the technology
used mostly people use polymerase chain
reaction or pcr
which is tech from the 1970s and this is
when you
use primers to amplify a specific little
segment
of a pathogen's genome to identify
whether it's present or
absent and again you're just it's very
targeted and limited and i'll go into
some issues
later comparing pcr to nextgen
sequencing
so the result is that there are 18
million diagnostic errors annually
and these results in patient suffering
and death
high diagnostic failure leads to as i
mentioned increased mortality
um and also improper antibiotic usage
and so this leads to you know broad
spectrum antibiotic usage
or they're using the wrong antibiotics
which then
increases the risk of drug-resistant
development and dangerous side effects
so really time is crucial in infectious
disease rapid
targeted treatment leads to higher
survival and shorter hospital stays
and drug resistance is a global crisis
the world health organization declared
it as a major threat to public health
and the problem is growing so it's
projected that by 2050
there'll be 10 million drug resistant
related
drug release resistance related deaths
so
far outpacing cancer and many other
pathogens
fortunately over the last decades the
last two decades we've been
in the midst of a revolution in science
which is the genomic revolution
um and this is characterized by this
advances
in sequencing technology which allows us
to
ma to sequence massive amounts of data
and has seen this has been enabled by
this
uh precipitous drop in sequencing costs
so it's actually been a 100 100 000 x
drop in sequencing
and this leads to the ability to cheaply
and quickly sequence
dna and rna and it promises to
revolutionize
all aspects of medicine from cancer to
infectious disease diagnostics
so a little bit more about the current
gold standard of pcr versus next-gen
sequencing
so um pcr is and again this this slide
is actually kind of focused on
viruses but it can you can extend this
to bacteria and fungi as well
but pcr is limited and targeted
it can't recognize new strains because
you have to design the primers ahead of
time to recognize a specific sequence
of uh your target and that
is different from uh comparison to
next-gen sequencing in
that with next-gen sequencing we
actually can
recover the full genome of the pathogen
and this allows us to recognize new
strains that are evolving
um we can look at genetic variation and
do phylogenetic analysis
so we can really use it from a public
health perspective to see
how pathogens are evolving changing
the accuracy on the second line here for
pcr
is really um we have high sensitivity
and high specificity
for this target stream specifically but
then again if you
apply that for emerging strains or
novel pathogens it's not going to work
there again because you have to design
it for a specific sequence that you have
in mind
next-gen sequencing on the other hand
has high sensitivity and specificity
and can also recognize these of all the
strange sizes in the database
for scaling um pcr is less capable for
scaling
and as we've seen with the kovid 19
pandemic
there are supply chain issues um
there have been widely and with next-gen
sequencing we can
scale it and do higher throughput with
automation
moving on to value for rtpcr
um it's really limited to detection so
presence absence of a pathogen
with next-gen sequencing we can look at
detection
and quantify amount of different
pathogens there
so there's uses in epidemiology and
public health
and applications for pcr are really
diagnostic it's a wonderful diagnostic
tool
it's quick and cheap um for next-gen
sequencing you can also use that for
diagnostics
and then you can also use it for
surveillance
therapeutic therapeutics and vaccine
development
and then also these early outbreak
detection and novel pathogen detection
so a little bit about how next-gen
sequencing works
so you can take a sample from a human or
from the environment
and you lyse the cells so generally
you're lysing human and microbial cells
if you're using this for
infectious disease diagnostics you
conduct
dna and or rna extraction depending on
what you're looking for and then that's
followed by library preparation
and sequencing on a next generation
sequence next generation sequencer
this is an illumina machine that's shown
here
we then take all of that massive data
that comes out of the sequencer
and process it with software and analyze
that
to make sense of microbial species
or you can also look for cancer
mutations if that is what you're
interested in
for most of the microbial detection
you basically are taking sequence data
off of the sequencer
and looking at sequences and comparing
that
to a database of known sequence data for
different pathogens
in order to find a match and identify if
a species is present
so some applications um that we've been
using uh ngs for next-gen sequencing or
ngs for
uh we've been working on environmental
testing pretty widely
and um as we know microbes are
everywhere they're all over us
everyone that's listening here all over
your room
um and most of the time this is fine
um but it can become problematic if you
have
uh uh if you're immunocompromised or
have
different issues as we often see in
hospitals
so in hospitals you'll often have
contagious patients that are housed
together with susceptible
patients and then you have all of the
cleaning challenges that go with this
and the result is that one in 25 people
who check into a hospital get an
infection
and one in nine of those people actually
die from that infection
and furthermore more than 70 percent of
those pathogens are
drug resistant so this is the big
problem
in hospitals hospitals that are
constantly battling um
microbes in their environment and also
the patient's own microbiome because the
patient can catch an infection from
their own microbiome
or from touching surfaces in the
hospital room or for
medical equipment
showing clostridium difficile here which
is actually
a has a name change but we'll just say
c diff so c diff is a common uh
hospital acquired infection that causes
diarrhea it can be drug resistant
and it lives for extended periods of
time on surfaces so it's been shown to
live for
up to five months on hard surfaces
there's a number of other pathogens like
staph aureus
and acinetobacter romani enterococcus
species
um that also live for extended periods
of time
so it's very important to
test the environment and see how
cleaning practices and interventions are
working there
so we've been working with while cornell
on this we did a two-year study
with them comparing five testing
approaches
so we compared atp which basically
measures organic matter on a surface
to test uh cleaning efficacy
we also use rhodec rodak plates and c
diff banana broth
um so different culturing methods to see
what's actually living there
and then we used uh next-gen sequencing
and all of this was to determine
cleanliness of the environment and
compare these sorts of approaches to
characterizing that
we found that ngs was the most
informative for
regularly identifying the causative
pathogens in each rooms of the infected
patients
so if a patient is infected we were able
to find the pathogens causing those
infections
in the room more frequently using ngs
ngs was also more sensitive than
culturing
uh for pathogens including procedures
and we presented these day uh this is
this
abstract at id week this poster at id
link uh in 2018.
we also did um work in ambulances across
the u.s
so this was the first sequencing based
study in a pre-hospital setting
and this was a national study of
ambulances so the map here shows
uh where we collected samples from and
we swabbed 13 surfaces in 137
ambulances and used ngs on that
and what we found was mostly
non-pathogenic species
but then we also saw evidence of
nosocomial pathogens so pathogens that
cause hospital hospital-acquired
infections
in 86 of the samples and then we saw
hits for antimicrobial resistance genes
in more than 90
of the samples so this represents this
shows basically a potential pathway for
pathogens and antimicrobial resistance
to enter hospitals
and also indicates that there may need
to be more regulation
of cleaning practices for ambulances
and this by the way was published in the
journal microbiome in 2017.
we've also extended our work to patient
testing
so we worked with a large
hospital in southeast asia bummer grad
international hospital
so they're located in bangkok thailand
and we used
next-gen sequencing on patient urine so
we
were engaged to process a thousand urine
samples and for these samples
they were split and they uh did their
traditional culturing approach
on it on the samples and then we also
did uh ngs testing
and the reason for this is we were um
looking
for pathogens causing utis urinary tract
infections
utis are one of the most common types of
infection and
about a third of utis go undiagnosed
and there's a lot of patients that have
recurrent utis and common cdis
that are drug resistant which in some
cases
for older patients especially can lead
to sepsis
so results-wise we found that
a third of the samples that were
cultured
yielded no results so culturing these
were
symptomatic patients that about about a
third of the samples
uh nothing grew in by culture
so we're in the process of analyzing
those data
further but um so far biosha
found uh using ngs that we were able to
identify
species and 80 percent of those samples
that
yielded nothing by culturing um we also
found 41
of those contained important uti
pathogens so
e coli and staph aureus which in some
ways was a little bit surprising because
e coli
is uh widely cultured and and
recognized to be pretty easy in the
culture but we were finding that we
still were finding e coli
in samples that culturing missed e coli
we also found that 30 of the samples
showed evidence of drug resistance
so one of the things we're doing now is
looking at patient records and seeing
how the patients were treated
and whether um testing and
treatment guidance using ngs data would
have influenced some of the outcomes
may have influenced some of the outcomes
um in these samples we also found a lot
more species
by using ngs or metagenomics
so on average we found 172 species
um and then by culturing we found
i'm sorry this was actually total
species detected
and then culturing we found 20 species
so it's much expanded
in ngs and then with validation we found
that 100 of control is passed
uh for the negative controls and then in
comparison with culturing results
we found 90 of the species found by
culturing using ngs
on the bottom here we show the top
antimicrobial resistance genes that we
are found
that we found one of the advantages of
using
ngs is that you don't have to do a lot
of
added tests to profile the microbiome
and then also the drug resistance
so in one test you can actually look for
drug resistance markers and virulence
markers
as well as the microbial profile
so some applications
in the current pandemic
just checking my time here
so applications um with covid19
so as you know coronavirus disease 2019
uh kovid19 has spread causing an
international public health emergency
we're currently almost at we're around
179 000 dead in the u.s alone
there's been an alarming global shortage
of coven 19 diagnostic tests
and almost all of the fda approved tests
currently
are rt pcr-based
so the technology that i was talking
about previously
so this can only um be used to identify
presence in
absence of the virus and doesn't provide
additional insight into the virus
um but you know in this situation we
definitely need to know more about this
virus to stop it
so we need to be able to quantify it and
see how it's evolving
and characterize mutations and strains
so some examples of some work some
studies that are coming out
showing the utility of knowing more
about the virus basically
viral load and disease severity um
have been shown to be correlated in some
samples
in some groups so um when we compare
just the asymptomatic patients to the
patients that have mild symptoms there
doesn't seem to be much of a difference
um but when researchers look at
mild cases uh compared to severe cases
as uh shown here this is some data from
zheng at all
it we see a significant difference
with higher viral loads for more severe
cases
in another study by payatas
there were a number of 1 145 patients
um were tested and it was found that
viral load
um was correlated with higher mortality
so there is some relevance here to
quantify
um level of the virus
and then similarly um it's important to
get an idea of the sequence of the virus
so that we can look at mutations and see
how the virus is evolving
so this here is
occasions i'm going to discuss the
mutations in the spike protein
so the spike protein is a trimeric
transmembrane glycoprotein complex
um it protrudes outward on the surface
of the virus so it's shown in blue
here on the right in the diagram
and so it really gives coronavirus it's
its name in that characteristic shape
uh the spike protein binds to the ace2
receptors in the host
and it's responsible for viral entry
into host cells
so we are seeing emergence of this
important
mutation in the spike protein which is
d614g
mutation and studies are showing that
this
d614 mutation d614g mutation
can increase the binding efficiency to
ace2
and it also may interact with the host
immune system making the infection more
acute
and may make the virus more
transmissible and pathogenic
so this is really the first mutation
that has
received a bit of
indication that it might have clinical
relevance but we also expect that as
the virus spreads and evolves
that we will see other mutations
emerging that will be important as well
so these mutations are good to note um
for how
we both both for treatment of the virus
and then containment of the virus
so we've been um working a bit on using
ngs for covid
for for the virus sarsko v2 which causes
covid19
um and we have been seeing
this ngs approaches providing these
other insights into the virus so
quantification
uh full viral sequence which allows us
to look at mutations
and uh can be used for surveillance of
the
you know entire stars cov2 viral genome
um so one of the things one of the tests
we're running is a
target enrichment of the virus from
samples
because the virus exists at really low
levels in samples
um and get swamped out like the signal
gets swamped out
because the human genome is so big when
you sequence it
so we've been doing this sort of um
hybrid capture
target enrichment for the total viral
genome
um and we're seeing very good coverage
when we do that so on the top
here these um this blue sort of
landscape or mountains
uh shows the sequence uh coverage
across the total viral genome the total
30 000 base pairs
so we see coverage across the the total
genome and then the red lines
here show different genetic variants
in a specific test sample and then on
the bottom here
we see this is compared to the global
database
so researchers have been collaborating
and
uh sequencing this is more than four
thousand samples
that have been deposited into this
database
of the gis aid database and this allows
us to
look in different regions of the world
and see
we can classify different clades of the
virus and different strains that are
merging
and track these key mutations like d614g
so of course there are still challenges
around ngs
and then there's a lot of exciting work
uh that we're starting to do and that we
see in the future
so some of the challenges are that there
are there is still a need for
standardization
before wider adoption in the clinic
so tests need to be reproducible across
time and space
if you have a patient that's tested in
new york in april
you need to be able to be able to
compare results
if they're retested in california six
months later
so one group working on this is the
international metagenomics microbiome
standards alliance
or imsa and our co-founder chris mason
has been working with them on this
and um they're doing a lot of comparison
between testing tools and kind of
benchmarking testing tools
there's a number of companies that are
building
um lab tools uh
like positive controls and stuff that we
can use
so zymo um has a microbial community
that you can always run and you know
uh how much of in your positive sample
how much of
x number of species uh you should be
finding
so these are generation of these
microbial standards and then all of this
feeds into
uh regulatory challenges right so
currently
the fda um has not approved any
meta genomic test which uses ngs to you
know profile the total microbiome
there's none of those tests that have
been uh fda approved
however there has been some changes
recently
the fda has approved approved a couple
tests
for emergency use authorization to use
ngs
uh to detect covid to detect sars
kobichu
um some other challenges are the high
rates of false positives
so this is when you have software that's
really using
a small segment of the genome to
identify a species
and oftentimes you have conservation or
conserved regions between
different species so
software might misidentify different
pathogens or microbial species
and there are ways to address this
computationally
you can incorporate looking at
more coverage across the genome is one
example something that we're working on
another problem on the clinical side
is that this sort of technology has a
really high sensitivity
and you're reporting a lot of pathogens
and sometimes clinicians might not want
to actually
see some of the pathogens that you're
reporting so
an example of this is uh c diff so
c diff um can be found um
carried by patients it can colonize
patients
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
there is a
c diff infection that needs to be
treated
so it's difficult for uh clinicians to
receive a seed of positive report and
then know what to do with that
so there's ways to address this by
looking
at basically one way is using artificial
intelligence to try to differentiate
between
what colonization looks like versus what
an infection that requires treatment
looks like
and then this requires of course more
better better data
and clinical metadata
so a little bit about the future
i'm just checking the time here okay i
think we're good
so a little bit more just about the
future of ngs and infectious disease
so we are already using ngs to profile
the microbiome
of whole cities internationally um this
is some
work that's being done by the medisub
group
um which again is is led by our
co-founder chris mason and we're
involved in a bit
um this gives us a really interesting
um baseline for cities and also we're
seeing is really important when you have
a pandemic
hit and you can um start to know what
your baseline is and
maybe you can use ngs for early
detection and studies and that sort of
thing
[Music]
um we've also been using to describe
using ngs to describe
novel strains of uh different species
collected from the space station
so we've been working with nasa on this
and we have a
couple papers coming out on that
and then ngs has really been providing
extraordinary insight into coven 19 and
you can look at next stream which is
available online which you can see the
spread of the pathogen globally and how
it's evolving
these different strains emerging it's
really amazing tool
and that is leveraging data again from
gis aid
so it's really an incredible example
of researchers working collaboratively
internationally
and making an incredible amount of
progress
um on this problem um so
the goal of course is to enable
personalized data-driven
disease management at all levels from
the individual to the society
at the individual level we want to
provide rapid insight for personalized
treatment to save each life
at the community level we want all these
data to feed into
a database like gis aid
for predictive analytics to drive
community health decisions
to aid in the development of
therapeutics and prediction
to contain emerging outbreaks and
ultimately we want to preserve the
efficacy of therapeutics
and inform the development of new
therapeutics including vaccines
and then preserve the shelf life of
antimicrobials
through judicious use of antimicrobials
and all of this is working towards
eradicating death due to infectious
disease
so i'd like to thank the bioshock team
including chris mason
uh dorati anaj zakal who's our chief
medical officer
at bioshock maryland mara
courtney heather joe all of the folks
working on this work
and then also the infectious disease
team at wow cornell
mason lab at weill cornell belmont grad
international hospital
lenko labs and the university of
tennessee health science center
and thanks for watching